[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zu sein ist es
heute gibt es ein update von unserem bau
die letzten wochen war baustopp einfach
viel zu warm bei viel zu kalt war
aber jetzt ist ja wieder die sonne
draußen ist jetzt auch schon ich sehe
euch kaum
und jetzt geht's auf dem bau wieder
weiter und natürlich habe ich ganz viele
fragen gesammelt von euch unter meinen
letzten bau videos und werde euch die
fragen beantworten und euch von bisschen
baum zeigen wie weit sind wir gerade auf
dem bau es stehen unten also im
erdgeschoss fast schon überall die
mauern als sich hier hinter mir
im vorderen bereich dafür denn die
mauern noch aber hinter euch da gehen
wir gleich sind das den die mauern
eigentlich schon ziemlich vollständig
oder hubert mooser kubicki am montag
kommt die decke genau das heißt ich
wollte eigentlich nur mit aufnehmen
aber die habe ich jetzt noch um drei
tage verspätet also nehmen was es beim
nächsten update einfach mit rein baby
update wurde ich schon sagen beim
nächsten update mit rein und kommt wir
laufen jetzt erstmal ein bisschen rum
und dann zeigt welche bissle was also
hier seht ihr von mauern dieses thema
zum beispiel in unserer garage in
unserer späteren und wir haben das so
ein bisschen aufgeteilt wo ich praktisch
videos drehen werde und wo wir dann eben
wohnen werden und es ist alles zusammen
aber doch schon so ein bisschen
strukturiert und getrennt hier ist wie
gesagt die kasse und dann kommt man
direkt aus der kasse in die
vorratskammer
denn ich brauche so dass man einfach
immer kurze weg gehabt das heißt zuerst
einmal war die grundidee meine küche
steht da und nehmen daran habe ich eine
vorratskammer und daneben dann habe ich
die garage und so musste praktisch mein
schwager atom-moratorium herum bauen mal
einfach für mich die küche so der
mittelpunkt meiner ganzen wohnung oder
meint aus und einfach nur jahr der
wichtigste ort also wenn wir mal ins
haus einbrechen will einfach über die
garage garage fahrt kam und dann in die
keller und genau hier setzt die
vorratskammer
alles ist auch toll richtig voll in
videos über die vorratskammer im rathaus
player an vergessen
hintergrund ist wir haben thema gekauft
die arbeiten jetzt hier gerade und
kammermusik ich glaube dann lassen wir
die jungs hier in ruhe arbeiten ja
soweit sie mir jetzt gerade und ihr seht
auch auf den raum überall finden gegeben
ist das gerüst und die machen jetzt
gerade auch diese sie heißen dass murat
dabei dem fenster was man hier so machen
ankauf lanka jetzt machen die grad lanka
und jahrhundert wahrscheinlich warum die
wände hier so hoch sind
aber bei uns ist es einfach so beträgt
momentan von zu hause aus und wenn wir
das problem dass die kamera einfach der
hof die kameraleute haben wir da dieses
league dran und wir möchten in zukunft
was die studio lichter also dieses diese
lichter die die küche bestrahlt einfach
an der decke hängen und dass man da eben
mich zusammenstößt müssen wir decken
einfach ein bisschen höher sein als drei
meter fünfzig gelaufen und damit wir
eben die je ein die eine seite jetzt
nicht hören die andere tiefe haben ist
eben überall im erdgeschoss zwei meter
fünfzig und dann haben wir das schön
einheitlich will dass ich auch sehr
schön aus mir gefällt es sehr gut und
vorwände und trotzdem ist es energetisch
da sieht man wie kleine auf trotzdem ist
energetisch da man eigentlich schon beim
nächsten stichpunkt und zwar bauen wird
energetisch wir bauen ja mit einem
betonstein 36 kind war und dass er
wirklich ein top also den muss man von
außen nicht isolieren
aber da gibt's auch bereits schon ein
video dazu könnt ihr euch mal anschauen
und wir werden auch weiterhin zeigen
dass der energetisch bauen wir da auch
am kalki förderkredit bekommen genau und
da zählt zum beispiel auch mit dass man
die fenster eben dementsprechend gut
wählt im richtigen moment und die
niedrigen u-wert unter besser geld genau
und bei der wehr werden eine wärmepumpe
haben und wir bauen auf heizungs für
auch erst mal klären lassen wir
produzieren praxis selbst so viele also
der produktion märz
also selber verbrauchen also wir sind
keineswegs auf andere strom angewiesen
eine ähnliche rechnung wer verbrennt zum
beispiel namen haben kein öl wir haben
das heißt wir werden in eine
photovoltaik-anlage unser strom selber
feuer und autark reinalter fordern wir
sind auf keinen mehr angewiesen auf
passivhaus dazu sagen wir versuchen das
hinzubekommen möglich ein ja aber
durchsagen ja also finde ich auch recht
gut und was später noch mit dem rad otto
wände fenster
man kann die fußbodenheizung sommer
umstellen einkünfte bürger auch chor so
dass theoretisch auch eine klimaanlage
auch das ist business ganz ganz kleine
tricks die man machen kann und die
kosten auch nicht viel mehr her im
endeffekt also ihr wisst dass ich war
windkanäle verrechnet sich sogar und auf
dem sommer extrem geachtet
hier sehe jetzt gerade in um vom
wohnzimmer in unserem zukünftigen und
hier hinter mir also hinter dieser
fensterfront ihrer zukünftigen weg
bringen uns das flüchtlingsheim und das
ist jetzt die südseite hinten auch keine
ahnung reden werden egal wo auf der
anderen seite gegenüber haben wir das
kernkraftwerk auf dieser seite haben
wenn du feigling unternehmen und da
drüben praktisch so das anliegende
gewerbe also ist wissen wir wirklich
mitten im gewerbegebiet und viele haben
mich gefragt hätte was treibt euch dahin
nie so baut die im gewerbegebiet und
macht euch nichts aus grad die
flüchtlinge da hinten oder eben das
ganze außen rum und ich muss echt sagen
nee das macht mir absolut nichts aus
wenn unser bewusst dafür entschieden
und vielleicht ein paar gründe beim
versteht was eigentlich auch momentan zu
versorgen wurden im dritten stock also
im dachgeschoss von einem
mehrfamilienhaus mit sechs parteien und
es ist halt so bei uns ist wirklich sehr
viel los es heißt mein team geht ein und
aus dann kommen pakete ständig und wenn
wir die mittel auf messen gehen müssen
wir manchmal auch morgens um drei oder
um 45 die sachen richten
kw laden autos ein und ausladen dann
kommen wir mitten in der nacht zurück 12
1 12 uhr 12 uhr
und es stört meine nachbarn natürlich
gern zwar bisher noch nie was gesagt
aber mich wird ja auch steuern also wenn
man das ständig im schlaf unterbrochen
wird und gestört wird und deswegen haben
wir das geht nun nicht mehr wohngebiet
können wir nicht es ist einfach zu viel
und zu viel lärm produzieren wir
deswegen sind wir ins gewerbegebiet
gezogen hätten natürlich auch so machen
können dass er im gewerbegebiet
praktisch und vermieter produzieren
das kleine frauen und dann im wohngebiet
eben r wohnen und meinen eltern wohnen
aber das problem ist ich möchte auch
arbeit und familie verbinden ich möchte
meine kinder um mich herum haben und
meine familie
und es ist ja auch so dass es dann macht
man einfach aufstehen slowake und das
auf instagram poster und deswegen müssen
wir natürlich da wohnen wo wir auch
arbeiten daher kam für uns ein neues
gewerbegebiet in frage die hier über
wochen zu teuer und wir im gewerbegebiet
ist hat auch wurde hat man auch eine
größere fläche und das haben wir uns
echt schön aufgeteilt also das wird
sozusagen den vorderen bereich nutzen um
zu arbeiten hier auch in unserem bereich
und oben dann eben einfach sagen ja auch
steuergründen hier gebaut muss dazu
sagen also geld sparen kann man hier
nicht denn wenn man im gewerbegebiet
auch wohnt muss man trotzdem für die
wohnfläche die man eben hat den normalen
kunststück preis bezahlen also das ist
nicht so dass man hier auch nur aus
gewerbegebiet preise zahlen von man muss
eben auch wohngebiet trainer und
ausnahme ganz tolle nachbarn solcher
nachbarn nebendran allerdings gleich
angeboten und kann aus zuleide jahre
andere hat gesagt erhöht bei der
telefonanlage helfen da merkst wie
wohnen ausländer und hier hilft man sich
gegenseitig ich habe gesagt ich kann nur
kuren und fahrten anbieten das heißt
wenn wir hier videos drehen und jammer
bakker und kocher dann kommt einfach
vorbei und genau und egal wie menschen
kuchen und lieben gruß an den
bürgermeister ist karl homole gebaut ist
es immer schön und wir freuen uns auch
wirklich auf alle nachbarn haben
wirklich gar kein problem mehr
und wir werden auch unser nachbar
zusammen backen kochen hoffentlich die
wir uns besuchen und somit stellen
man muss im leben immer so nämlich vom
jetzt soweit also der rohbau steht unten
jetzt auch noch nicht aber ich muss
jetzt an dieser stelle natürlich schon
wissen wo kommen so viele steckdosen hin
wie wichtig die lichter haben wo steht
in der küche zwei herren und der
backofen 40 abschluss und es ist für
mich natürlich sehr schwierig weil ich
mir im moment hier eigentlich gar nicht
vorstellen kann als ich weiß nicht wo
steht hier später mal im sofa ich weiß
was ungefähr aber es ist einfach
schwierig sich jetzt vorzustellen
und da muss ich natürlich auch ein
bisschen auf die experten verlassen das
heißt mein bruder zum beispiel macht die
elektrik der muss mit dem wagen ja mein
stil
hier und da die lichter ich hab mir ich
habe den tipp angenommen werden so viele
steckdosen wie möglich machen
denn bei uns in der wohnung ist nur dass
wir oft verlängerungskabel legen müssen
und es sieht gut aus und ist natürlich
eine zusätzliche stolperfalle
und ja neben jedem fenster steckdosen
überall steckdosen im boden vielleicht
noch steckdosen also auf jeden fall mehr
steckdosen als zu wenig hier seht da zb
die typische morath planung wir hatten
hier zwei beruf zu einem zusammengelegt
wird die frage was macht diese fenster
da oben kommt nicht dran
also muss daraus wieder einen bodentiefe
fenster gemacht werden
habt ihr jetzt selber gelegt kleine
fenster und hier ist gästeklo oder auf
der toilette sitzt der zeitung
wie die hasen im feld hoppe genau also
wenn jemand aus dem haus vorbei läuft
ich finde ich guck treiben winkt im rat
eine ach ja ich glaube lassen doch groß
ist zum beispiel im eingang und ich hab
mir du meine güte wie groß ist denn hier
brauchen wir doch gar nicht bis dann
jemand gesagt hat mich dann doch noch
die treppe hinauf das treppenhaus als
sie hinter mir kommt dann die treppe hin
und da wir gerne
licht mögen ist jetzt auch wenn viele
große fans dass wir auch in unserer
jetzigen wohnung
ich mag es einfach lichtdurchflutet
kommt hier auch eine stahltreppe hin
das heißt keine rettung treppe wurde
alle funkel wird von einem schöne offene
starbucks treppe und die wird denn hier
befinden und dann kommt man eben ins
obergeschoss als markt gewerbegebiet hin
und her wir sind hier direkt am feldrand
und ich bin zu action da kann man auch
schaut und vor allem bei uns ist summe
auf der bz vom kreis fahren und den
fernsehturm sehen dann ist man immer
dass er zu hause sind so sind sie hat
ganz ganz viele hasen als die vorigen
sommer schon hasen jagen umwelt gibt den
hasen hinterher dass die hasen mir und
dieser mir abhängen
es läuft alles auf diesen schönen das
internet erscheinen sind sobald sie ihr
thema jetzt wieder in der garage und
keller der garage haben wir einen
technikraum und zwar kommt der die ganze
technik hin also g2 kraft wärme pumpen
dann die ganzen elektrokasten atrium
tipp alles was mit dem haus zu tun hat
man genau und mit lange telefonanlage
und damals an meinem beruf meine eigene
du dir selbst video was wünschen dann
machen sich baumann wort einzug ins
eurocup spiel gegen hamburg hatte zwar
schon wieder am fenster wunder dran
kommt aber diesmal komme ich gar nicht
ob ich nach jeder baumann knopf zum
aufmachen
hier vorne in dem bereich wo es noch
keine wende stehen da kommen wir bringt
dann auch noch weitere büros sind und
ihr kommt auch meine büchereien von
besser auf die videos drehen werde
also sehr schön und ja hier spielt sich
dann im grunde fast alles ab also hier
vorne hinten noch ein bisschen und yahoo
hat kann ich sagen dass mich das diesel
anstrebt of grain ab wie die titanic
nach dem fenster gesehen habe wir gehen
unter
ich glaube nicht also jedenfalls war das
ein kleiner einblick in den bau und die
mittel für mittelwände drin haben genau
genau wird sollen die wände drin haben
wir werden jetzt auch filmen wie die
decke drauf kommt der film nicht so voll
faszinieren weiß kommt da dann einfach
wenn es dann drauf gegossen oder kommt
also das heutige platte ich habe keine
ahnung
vielleicht jemand ich hab halt noch nie
gebaut und bin auch nicht vom bau ich
kann nur kuchen backen und stapeln oder
alles andere hat das riesengroße
komplett darauf wird extra wieder
vorüber okay und ich glaube euch
interessiert ist wahrscheinlich auch
deswegen zeigen wir dass hier und
nächste woche in meinem nächsten bau
video geht es um meine küche denn ich
muss mich jetzt wie gesagt schon an die
küchenplanung machen aber da erfahrt ihr
mehr und falls ihr die anderen teile
verfasst hat schaut euch die übrigen bei
videos an
also ich hoffe ich heute eure fragen
beantworten falls ihr noch wenn sie habt
stellt sie gerne unten in den
kommentaren und was ich noch sagen
wollte
ich hab nur ein paar kommentare erhalten
von zuschauern und auch ein paar schon
hier entdeckt die auf dem bau waren und
nicht wieder euch weg vom nicht hierher
bekommen es geht dabei nicht um uns
sondern um euch um eure sicherheit und
das ist wirklich sehr gefährlichen steht
der kran rum institut viel equipment
herum geschieht und es ist gefährlich
meinen gefährlicher ist natürlich wenn
der murat anwesend ist humor ist die
größte gefahr hier auf der baustelle
warum war ich meine das wirklich nur für
eure sicherheit
warum wenn mein ruf kaputt gehen nicht
eine fensterreihe später mit dem wasser
murat wird ist wieder raus gesagt wir
machen da nicht mit ihm habe ich im haus
geholt wenn starke klar seine meinung
vielleicht bringt die st aber schön dass
es solche